-Our next guest
is a comedian and writer
whose book, "Jews Don't Count,"
is available now.
Please welcome to the show
David Baddiel.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-How are you?
-I'm all right.
Actually, I'm jet-lagged
'cause I flew in from London,
so I was up at 4:00 a.m.
this morning.
But it's okay
'cause I'm an insomniac.
-Oh, okay. So, yeah, kind of
those dovetail together nicely.
-Yeah, but the thing is --
You didn't do it,
but when you tell people
you're an insomniac,
I've noticed, they often say,
"Oh, I'm always asleep as soon
as my head hits the pillow."
And I always want to say,
"Right, if I told you
I was blind, would you have
said, 'Oh, really?
I can see perfectly'"?
[ Laughter ]
-You're right. It's very unfair
that they do that.
-It really is, yeah.
-I'm so glad now, looking back,
that I didn't say that.
-Yeah, I'm glad you didn't.
-'Cause it's true, David.
As soon as it hits the pillow...
[ Laughter ]
So I know you to be --
You're a comedian,
you're a writer,
you've written screenplays.
I did not realize this
about you.
You wrote a football anthem.
-Thanks for calling it football.
-Well, I know
who I'm talking to, right?
-I thought
you were gonna say soccer,
and I was gonna have to claim
"No, we got there first."
Yeah, no, that is one of
the things I am
very well-known for in England,
which is that, in 1996,
me and another comedian
and a band, The Lightning Seeds,
we wrote a song called
"Three Lions
(Football's Coming Home),"
and it has gone to number one
in England four times.
It holds the record for going
to number one four times.
And the problem with that is,
that my voice is [bleep]
That's what my voice is.
[ Laughter ]
-And, like, George Michael
and Freddie Mercury
must be turning in their graves
at the thought of it.
It got -- When it came out --
I mean, it is really popular.
Right?
It gets sung at the grounds.
The Queen goes on TV and says
"Football's coming home,"
and some --
it's really, really popular.
But it got, like,
the worst review anything's,
I think, ever got when it first
came out from "Q" magazine.
-Yeah, sure,
I remember "Q" magazine.
-Okay.
So "Q" magazine said --
It started off well.
It said, "In the future,
people will think of
'Three Lions'
as better than it was.
In the future," they said,
"folk memory will erase
the memory of David Baddiel's
singing just as effectively
as it has erased the memory
of corpse robbers
during the Blitz."
[ Laughter ]
I'm, like, almost proud to be
insulted on such a scale.
-It really is.
But just to give people a sense,
this is a song you wrote being
sung at football grounds.
-Yeah.
-Let's just take a listen.
♪ It's coming,
football's coming home ♪
♪ It's coming home,
it's coming home ♪
♪ It's coming,
football's coming home ♪
-There are more lyrics
than what we showed there.
-Yeah, there are.
-I feel that doesn't show
the breadth of your work.
-You're a sports fan, right?
-I am, yeah.
-Okay. So, the main lyrics
are about how England
are gonna lose, probably,
because that is actually
the history of England
at big tournaments,
but we think somehow
they're gonna win.
And that's what chimed, I think,
with football fans.
But I tell you something,
when it first got sung like that
at Wembley Stadium,
it was, like,
I didn't know
it was gonna happen.
I'm sitting there
with Frank Skinner,
who also wrote it, and,
suddenly, we've beaten Scotland,
and the whole stadium erupts.
And everyone knows the words,
right?
-Yeah, you made it pretty easy.
-Well, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, I did.
I knew what I was playing with
these football fans, right?
But that was amazing.
It's sort of --
You know you're meant to say
that the best day of your life
is when your kids are born.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, [bleep] that.
That was the best day
of my life.
[ Laughter ]
-I believe it.
-It was really amazing, yeah.
-I want to talk about
what's inside the book,
but let's start with the title.
It's very provocative,
to say the least.
It was very strange to say it
to the audience tonight.
-Okay.
I noticed you qualified it
by saying,
"He argues that they do."
-Yeah, or they should, I guess,
is really what you argue.
-Well, the title is provocative,
and a few people have --
and, like, a woman wrote to me
from here, from New York,
saying, "I've tried to read this
in the hair salon,
and I got some weird looks."
Right?
But in Germany -- so, this
book's come out in Germany,
which perhaps shows
what the problem is.
[ Laughter ]
It's come out in Germany,
and the German publishers
wrote to me,
and they actually said,
"We can't call it --"
It's "Juden zahlen nicht" --
"Jews Don't Count," in Germany.
They wrote me
this very serious e-mail.
They said, "With our history."
And I was tempted to troll them
and say, "Sorry. What history?"
-Yeah, exactly.
[ Laughter ]
-"What are you talking about?"
See how long I could keep
that going for.
-Right, right, right.
-But eventually they said,
"No, we can't do it," and they
called it something else.
You've got it there.
They called it "Und die Juden?"
question Mark, which means,
"And The Jews?", question mark,
which sounds creepier to me.
-Yeah!
-It sounds more like something
that an S.S. general would say
to, like, Hitler.
Like, that's the last thing
they say in the meeting,
and he just looks really cross.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, yeah.
-This is a book where you argue
that anti-Semitism
should be judged
the same as racism,
that it is, in fact, racism, and
it's often not valued the same.
-Well, it's a book about
the anti-race --
the identity politics
conversation.
-Yeah.
-And about how,
in that conversation,
which has intensified incredibly
over the last 20 years, it seems
to me that anti-Semitism,
which is a very old racism,
very old form of discrimination,
is kind of very low
in the mix of that.
It kind of feels like people
aren't so bothered about it.
I start the book with about
12 examples of this.
For example,
I'm sitting at home,
I'm listening to Jeremy Irons
in 2019 read out
all of T.S. Eliot's poetry
on BBC Radio 4,
which is a very kind of
posh thing.
And I know that I'm gonna get
to lunchtime,
and he's gonna read out
the lines, which are real lines
from T.S. Eliot, "The rats
are underneath the piles,
the Jew is underneath the lot."
And my point is not that
T.S. Eliot is an anti-Semite.
We know it. The point is,
where's the reaction to that?
In a trigger space that we exist
in, from microaggression
against all minorities,
why is Twitter not alive
with fury at that and statues
of T.S. Eliot being toppled?
I'm not asking
for that to happen.
I'm asking why there is no
conversation about it.
-And why -- it must have
occurred to you
and your publishers, as well,
coming at it
from a comedian's perspective,
it doesn't seem like necessarily
a topic that would be rich for,
you know, sort of
comic mining of the material.
What made you decide to want to
approach it in the first place?
-Well, I don't just do comedy.
I've become --
As I get older --
I find, as I get older,
I'm allowed to talk about
serious stuff.
-Yeah.
-There is jokes in it.
I talk about, in fact, meeting
a Jewish football commentator
who interviewed me once and told
me once he wasn't Jewish.
And then I met him later on
at the World Cup in Japan
in a sauna, and he was.
-Okay, yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-So there are jokes in it.
Right? Right?
But, yeah, it's mainly serious.
I mean, the point
you made about racism,
I note, in America,
this is a more complex thing,
is that there seems
to be a problem with calling
anti-Semitism racism.
And if you want the argument
for it, I'm an atheist.
But that would get me no
free passes out of Auschwitz.
I've noticed
that white supremacists,
they don't check whether
I keep kosher before they think,
"I'll burn down
that Jew's house."
Do you know what I mean?
-Sure.
-Right? So, for me,
it's an accident of birth
that the racists hate me for,
and so, therefore, it's racism.
And, you know, I mean,
as it happens,
being an atheist and a Jew
is kind of a weird thing
because people
don't understand that, either.
But, basically,
I don't believe in God,
I believe in Larry David.
It's quite straightforward
for me, right?
Actually, can I just
tell you a quick story?
-Please.
-Because I use that sometimes
to get out of --
Because it's very common
being an atheist and a Jew,
but I use it sometimes
to get -- because
I'm well-known in Britain --
to get out of stuff
I get asked to do
by the local Jewish community.
So this rabbi rang me up.
My local rabbi --
I've never met him --
somehow got my number --
and says,
"Can you light the menorah,
the big menorah, in London?
You come and light it, because
you're kind of Mr. Jew, right?"
[ Laughter ]
And I didn't want to do it.
So I played what I thought --
my trump card.
I said,
"I'm sorry to tell you this,
rabbi, but I'm an atheist."
He said, "So am I."
I thought "[Bleep]
I mean, like --"
[ Laughter ]
How common has that become
amongst Jews, right?
-I know that when you write
about something
that is this provocative
in topic,
you're gonna hear from,
you know, both sides.
But I heard that you have
an Internet troll of a sort
living in your own home.
-I do have that.
I have my son Ezra, who --
I don't know if
you've got a teenage son.
-No, not yet.
-But it is like living
with a, yeah, an Internet troll.
He likes to humiliate me,
and he uses, I guess,
my public profile against me,
to some extent.
But he's clever,
and he's good with technology.
So, for example,
we were in Cornwall last summer,
and it's by the sea.
And I was just driving there
with my family, and that summer,
my car stereo had packed up.
So I was using a -- like,
a Bluetooth personal speaker
for the music in the car.
And it's just on the dashboard.
We get out of the car.
It's a really crowded car park.
I'm holding that in front of me
because I think,
"I don't want it to be stolen."
I'm holding that.
I'm holding, like, swimming
costumes and towels or whatever.
It was really awkward.
I noticed that Ezra
is doing something
with his phone,
but I'm not really
paying attention.
Then suddenly,
this speaker starts playing,
incredibly loudly,
this incredibly Jewish music.
Right?
[ Laughter ]
[ Vocalizing to the tune of
"Hava Nagila" ]
And I could see all the people
in the car park look around
and clearly think, "Oh, look,
there's David Baddiel."
[ Laughter ]
"I guess he must
have to have music like that
around him all the time.
Any minute now,
he'll be doing this, I imagine."
[ Laughter ]
-Got to love a teenage kid
who can take it out of his dad.
-You know what?
I was humiliated,
but I was proud
because that is a good gag.
-Yeah, exactly.
-Yeah.
-It feels like he ticks
both the boxes of Judaism
and comedy in the same moment.
-Exactly.
That's what
I would want for him.
-Thank you so much
for being here.
Congratulations on the book.
-It's lovely to be here.
-That's David Baddiel,
everybody.
"Jews Don't Count" is on sale
now wherever books are sold,
but please support local
and independent bookstores.